in der Phoenix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Kevin Kühnert ist bei uns der
Generalsekretär der SPD Carsten
Linnemann stellvertretender
Bundesvorsitzender CDU und Vorsitzender
der Programmkommission sie erarbeiten im
Auftrag des Vorsitzenden ein neues
Parteiprogramm an der Lehmann leitet das
parlamentsbüro der taz hier in Berlin
und Daniel koffert Schöffel Reporter der
Wirtschaftswoche und Autor eines Buches
mit dem Titel der unbeugsame Friedrich
Merz die Union und der Kampf um die
Macht
ist eigentlich noch Bürgergeld drin wo
Bürgergeld drauf steht Friedrich März
hat er gestern durchaus interessant
angemerkt dass das Gesetz sein im Wesen
nach so verändert worden ist durch den
Einfluss der Union das ist den Namen
Bürgergeld eigentlich gar nicht mehr
verdienen man könnte es auch weiterhin
Hartz IV nennen
sie haben sich über den Tisch ziehen
lassen
nee und wenn es so wäre dann wäre
Friedrich Merz bestimmt nicht derjenige
der
neutral dieses Urteil sprechen könnte
also machen wir uns mal nichts vor auch
für die weitere Diskussion da ist jetzt
ein Kompromiss gefunden worden es gehört
zum normalen Geschäft das jetzt
natürlich jeder versucht nachzuweisen
dass das eigentlich ganz nah am eigenen
Programm dran ist wir haben da glaube
ich ein bisschen den Vorteil bei uns ist
ja dieses Bürgergeld mal entwickelt
worden im sozialstaatskonzept der SPD
bei dem wir das nachfolgekonzept zu
Hartz IV entwickeln wollten und alle
wesentlichen Eckpfeiler die wir damals
zusammengetragen haben die finden wir
heute auch darin wieder es ging um den
Kulturwandel in den Jobcentern um den
Vorrang von Qualifizierung und
Weiterbildung vor der schnellen
Vermittlungen irgendeine Hilfstätigkeit
nur um die Leute aus den Statistiken
rauszukriegen das ist gewährleistet und
einiges andere mehr worüber wir heute
sprechen werden wir sind durchaus sehr
zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis
weil man jetzt die Ampel zum einen
lenken bewegen konnte da machten über
das Verhalten der Union Begriffe wie
Häme Schadenfreude Arroganz die Runde
wäre da nicht etwas mehr etwas mehr an
das Statement angebracht gewesen
weiß ich nicht die kommentarlage heute
war ja auch klar trotzdem hat der kühn
hat recht der Kompromiss ist jetzt
gefunden worden und uns war es extrem
wichtig dass das Prinzip Fördern und
Fordern weiter
stattfindet in Deutschland in diesem
Lande und genau das haben wir geschafft
und deswegen sind wir mit diesem
Kompromiss sehr zufrieden Frau Lehmann
ist denn das
ursprüngliche bürgergeldgesetz der Ampel
kommt wieder zu erkennen jetzt in der
neuen Fassung
ja die Frage ist das jetzt entkernt oder
kernsaniert die haben wir uns auch
gestellt ich würde sagen es ist ein
Kompromiss in dem vieles drin ist von
dem was die Ampel ursprünglich wollte
einige Punkte die besonders ich würde
mal sagen den Grünen wichtig waren es
sind rausgefallen zum Beispiel die
vertrauenszeit und ein Punkt ist schon
auf dem Weg zu diesem Bürgergeld
rausgefallen der ursprünglich auch mal
ihre Partei wichtig war nämlich eine
andere Berechnung der Regelsätze das war
innerhalb der Ampel dann schon nicht
konsensfähig insofern bleibt bei diesen
Arm gerechnet in Regelsätzen es wird
keine andere Berechnungsgrundlage geben
also es sind viele Dinge von denen was
sie wollten drin aber ein wesentlicher
fehlt dann eben doch
sie haben dieses Buch über Friedrich
Merz geschrieben der Auftritt gestern
von ihm da im Bundestag tut das dem
Image des
Parteivorsitzenden der CDU gut
ja man wirft ihm dann vor dass er sehr
triumphfahrer Auftritt das soll manchmal
arrogant Auftritt
er hat möglicherweise diese Art weil
auch sehr groß ist das wird auch viele
die kleiner sind ein bisschen von oben
herab manchmal er hat natürlich auch die
Rolle als Oppositionsführer also er muss
schon auch scharf angreifen aber wir
erinnern uns ja nun auch eine Menge
Dinge wo er versucht hat mit der
Regierung auch zusammenzugehen bei
wichtigen Fragen zum Beispiel was z.B
dieses Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
das ging ja auch nur mit Zustimmung der
Union er hat in dieser schwierigen Zeit
wo viele Leute glaube ich mehr den je
von der Opposition erwarten dass sie die
Regierung unterstützt weil Krisenzeiten
werden immer als besonders dringend
wahrgenommen die Aufgabe zwischen
natürlich auf der einen Seite
Kooperation auf der anderen Seite aber
notwendige Opposition zu chancieren und
das ist ein Balanceakt und manchmal
trifft es und manchmal vielleicht nicht
so ganz
jetzt können Kühnert was da rausgefallen
ist was die Ampel ursprünglich drin
hatte war ja diese vertrauenszeit von
einem halben Jahr da waren keine
Sanktionen geplant jetzt sind sie vom
ersten Tag an geplant die Karenzzeit ist
und die Hälfte gekürzt worden die daran
enthaltenen Schonvermögen bzw die
Finanzierung der Wohnung auch jeweils um
50% gekürzt worden ist man auf die Union
zugegangen man hatte immer gesagt Hartz
IV das heißt sozusagen die Abschaffung
sei die Trauma Bewältigung der SPD seit
knapp 20 Jahren wird das jetzt mit
diesem Kompromiss wirklich gelingen weil
vieles von dem was sie ja versprochen
hatten was der Arbeitsminister
versprochen hatte ja dann nicht drin
steht
also natürlich ist das ein wichtiger
Diskussionspunkt in der Sozialdemokratie
die letzten 15 Jahre gewesen wer wäre
ich zu bestreiten dass es so war wir
haben die Reform aber nicht auf den Weg
gebracht um uns von irgendwas zu
befreien sondern weil wir wirklich der
Überzeugung waren und das ja auch
gedeckt durch die Berichte aus vielen
Jobcentern und von Betroffenen dass das
System an vielen Stellen nicht gerecht
war und übrigens auch nicht mehr in die
Zeit gepasst hat in eine Zeit mit
zweieinhalb Millionen Erwerbslosen und
Fachkräftemangel da müssen andere
Instrumente gefunden werden dafür war
das gedacht die Punkte bei denen jetzt
Zugeständnisse gemacht wurden die Sie
gerade genannt haben sind dann aber auch
schon alle bei den Zugeständnisse
gemacht wurden und um das noch einmal zu
sortieren in dieser vertrauenszeit die
ursprünglich vorgesehen war hätte es
auch Mitwirkungspflichten gegeben jetzt
ist es eben so dass nicht beim zweiten
Termin Versäumnis 10% Abzüge vom
Regelsatz gemacht werden sondern schon
beim ersten ich könnte jetzt fünf
Minuten erklären erspare uns das aber
warum ich die Ursprungsversion für die
bessere halte aber das darin der ganze
Kern des Bürgergeldes gegangen hätte und
der nun weg wäre das kann man wirklich
nicht sagen und ja das ist schade dass
das jetzt nur ein Jahr geschütztes
Vermögen und Wohnungen gibt insbesondere
zum Beispiel für Menschen und mal ganz
praktisch zu werden die in der
qualifizierungs- und
Weiterbildungsmaßnahme sind die nämlich
häufig nicht nach einem Jahr vorbei ist
und die dann mitten in dieser Maßnahme
eine Abbruchkante haben werden aber so
ist das wenn Kompromisse gefunden werden
müssen dafür haben wir viel anderes nach
Hause gebracht jetzt gibt es diesen
vermittlungsvorrang nicht mehr das also
sobald eine Stelle frei ist jemand der
arbeitslos ist dahin muss damit die
Statistik stimmt möglichst wenig
Arbeitslosen Statistik zu haben es wird
jetzt mehr Wert gelegt auf Qualifikation
auf Weiterbildung gerade im
angesichts des
Fachkräftemangels können Sie damit gehen
oder ist Ihnen das so eine so schnell
wie möglich in den Job zu gehen lieber
also ich bin der letzte der was gegen
Weiterbildung hat es gibt ja jetzt eine
Kooperationsvereinbarung und man schaut
was braucht man es gibt Menschen die
kommt zu uns die brauchen einen
sprachkur eine Integrationskurs der ist
es besser erstmal die Sprache zu lernen
bevor man dann in Arbeit geht völlig
richtig aber dass man etwas machen muss
das findet jetzt wieder statt ansonsten
wird man
sanktioniert und das halte ich halt für
extrem wichtig erster Punkt zweiter
Punkt Herr Killer wir geben jetzt schon
sieben Milliarden Euro für Weiterbildung
und Bildung aus nicht so dass wir nichts
gemacht haben und der dritte Punkt ist
wir müssen einfach mal sehen es gibt in
Deutschland 3,8 Millionen Hartz IV
Empfänger es gibt 2,5 Millionen Menschen
im Arbeitslosengeld 1 das heißt wir
haben über 6 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland die Arbeit suchen davon gibt
es viele die nicht arbeiten können ich
denke auch mal anderes Thema an die
erwerbsgemindert und da gibt's 1,8
Millionen Menschen die wollen gerne
arbeiten können aber aufgrund einer
Krankheit nicht mehr etc wir müssen in
Deutschland darüber reden wie wir die
Menschen wieder in Arbeit bringen und es
ist doch ihre dass wenn Sie hier in
Berlin in die Stadt gehen da gehen sie
in ein einzelhandelsgespräch in ein
einzelhandelsladen rein der ist ein
Schild der steht drin sie brauchen sich
gar nicht bewerben fangen sie an in den
gesamten Gastronomie da machen zum Teil
mittags die Restaurants zu weil sie
niemanden finden und deshalb war es so
wichtig dass wir dieses Fördern und
Fordern mit eingebaut haben weil ich bin
mir sicher dass es viele Menschen gibt
in Deutschland auch diejenigen die zu
uns kommen
das Arbeit für sie da ist und sie das
auch annehmen sollten dann ich meine wir
haben es noch niemals im Sommer
geschafft wenn ich das noch sagen darf
wo wir diesen Koffer Chaos hatten da an
den Flughäfen und an den Bahnhöfen
machen was noch niemals geschafft
irgendwie 1000 Menschen zu motivieren da
zu helfen ich war mit mit 14 keine keine
Fachkräfte von denen ich jetzt gerade
gesprochen habe also insofern ist es ja
geht ja nicht nur darum jetzt
irgendwelche Lücken zu fühlen sondern
gezielt jemand in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren ähm das ist ja auch wenn man
eine Fachkraft ist ja nicht nur mit mir
ein Komfort verbunden sondern auch mit
möglicherweise einem sicheren
Arbeitsplatz
absolut aber nehmen Sie nur mal
diejenigen die zu uns kommen es gibt ja
viele die in Deutschland leben und
eingezahlt haben die kriegen ja erstmal
Arbeitslosengeld 1 schon mal 18 bis 24
Monate vorher aber es gibt auch viele
Menschen die kommen nach Deutschland und
ich finde da muss man auch das Signal
geben berechtigt nehmen wir mal zum
Beispiel die Syrer die haben eine sehr
hohe Anerkennungsquote wir haben
trotzdem seit 2015 jetzt hunderttausende
die in Hartz 4 Leben und da finde ich es
wichtig dass wenn Menschen zu uns kommen
wissen wir unterstützen dich auch mit
dem Sozialsystem aber es ist ein
steuerfinanziertes Sozialsystem und
deswegen erwarten wir auch dass du
arbeiten gehst und Sprachkurs macht und
so weiter
arbeiten kann
Friedrich Merz hat ja gestern gesagt er
war ganz überrascht wie leicht es
eigentlich war die Position der Union
gegenüber der Ampel durchzusetzen so
dass zumindestens gesagt da
möglicherweise auch eine Rolle gespielt
dass bei einer Umfrage im ZDF
Politbarometer 68 Prozent die Kritik der
Union geteilt haben bei dem ersten
Entwurf das Bürgergeld gebe viel zu
wenig Anreize der Arbeit aufzunehmen
bisschen jetzt möglicherweise das auch
der Grund gewesen warum die Ampel da auf
die Union stark zugegangen ist um diesen
Vorwurf zu entkräften ich glaube ich
glaube schon
ich glaube es liegt auch daran dass die
Ampel die gesellschaftliche Debatte in
Teilen verloren hat also das was sie
jetzt skizzieren es gibt 3,8 Millionen
Arbeitslose und bzw ALG2 Empfänger und
davon sind ganz viele die wohl
da gibt's ja Jobs immer die wollen nicht
arbeiten also diesen Eindruck zu
erwecken das hat tatsächlich gezogen
tatsächlich ist es ja gar nicht so nur
40% derer die im arbeitslos weil die
Arbeitslosengeld 2 beziehen sind
tatsächlich als erwerbsfähige Person
also gelten als erwerbsfähig und viele
von denen die im Arbeitslosengeld zwei
sind haben auch sogenannte multiple
Vermittlungshemmnisse also die können
diese Jobs die da angeblich
da sind überhaupt nicht ausführen sie
können nicht im Lager arbeiten weil sie
haben es im Rücken oder sie können die
Schichtarbeit machen weil sie haben
irgendwie noch Kinder zu betreuen oder
eine kranke Mutter also so einfach ist
es ja nicht und selbst die von Ihnen
erwähnten Koffer Jobs das sind nicht
einfach Jobs die jeder dahergelaufene
machen kann da braucht man auch eine
Sicherheitscheck also die Debatte da
gibt's angeblich also wir haben offene
Stellen und es gibt dann gibt es ganz
viele ALG2 Empfänger die wollen lieber
all die zwei beziehen als zu arbeiten
ich glaube das hat verfangen obwohl das
auch die Spreizung zwischen
dem Arbeitskräftemangel und der
Arbeitslosen Arbeitslosigkeit weit
überwinden das heißt also wir haben
relativ viele offene Stellen
Arbeitslose sind gibt es auch einige
aber da könnte man natürlich die
Arbeitslosigkeit durch die vielen
offenen Stellen auch abbauen das klingt
wie so ein Nullsummenspiel ist das so
einfach oder wo liegen da die
Möglichkeiten das zu verbessern also so
einfach ist natürlich nicht wie am
853.000 offene Stellen in Deutschland
und 200 Millionen Arbeitslose also man
kann nicht diese Rechnung so aufmachen
also wenn die erstmal alle die Stellen
besetzen dann sind die Arbeitslosigkeit
um die Zahl der offenen Stellen weil es
gibt ja regional große Unterschiede also
gibt's in meinem Osten viel mehr
Arbeitslosigkeit und viel weniger offene
Stellen aber und ich glaube das ist auch
der Kern der Debatte
natürlich gibt es Leute die aus vieler
Gründe nicht arbeiten können aber machen
uns nichts vor es gibt auch Leute die
keine Lust haben zu arbeiten und die
sind in diesem System auch ganz gut
eingerichtet haben und es ist niemals
schwarz oder das ist weiß und ich glaube
dass sie SPD vor allen Dingen und
deshalb so schnell nachgegeben hat weil
sie diese Umfrage auch gelesen hat und
weil sie natürlich was wenn zwei Drittel
der Befragten der Meinung sind dass die
Regelung so wie sie ist nicht in Ordnung
ist dann sind das ja nicht nur cdu-welle
oder FDP Wähler sondern das sind ja in
den weiten Teilen Arbeitnehmerschaft
auch Leute gewesen und es sind natürlich
auch Wähler der SPD und die haben dann
schon gemerkt dass ihnen da die Truppen
laufen gehen bei dieser Frage es gibt
einen alten Sprachen arbeite Bewegung
wer essen will muss auch arbeiten und
ich glaube das ist bei vielen Leuten
drin die auch jeden Tag arbeiten ihre
SPD wählen und die deshalb mit dieser
Regelung nicht so glücklich waren und
das ist möglicherweise dann auf der SPD
ein bisschen leichter gefallen und dem
Punkt nachzugehen etwas wachshausen
bekommen von dieser Umfrage an anderen
dass man tatsächlich auch SPD Wähler
sagen also so wie das Bürgergeld
ursprünglich geplant war so akzeptieren
war nicht es ist ja ganz offen gesagt
und 68 % ist ja eine große Mehrheit die
sagt
das schafft nicht wirklich Anreize
Arbeit anzunehmen
und das das gefühlsgetriebe gewesen nach
der Diskussion der letzten Wochen es
würde mich dann übrigens schon wenn man
das am Freitag in Sack und Tüten haben
in Bundestag und Bundesrat mit ein
bisschen Abstand auch noch mal
interessieren auch in Richtung der Union
ist es das jetzt eigentlich wert gewesen
eine Debatte zu führen und dort das ein
oder andere Zugeständnis zu kriegen um
den Preis das jetzt viele Menschen in
Deutschland Fakten fremd davon ausgehen
dass wir ganz viele faule Arbeitslose
haben die sich nicht anstrengen wollen
und dass das eine sehr große zu
benennende Gruppe ist auf jeden Fall
viel mehr als die tatsächlich in zwei
drei Prozent die ausweislich allem was
wir aus den Jobcentern Wissen
tatsächlich vorhanden sind sie hat eine
Verzerrung der Diskussion stattgefunden
und die wird uns noch lange in den
Klamotten hängen Union hat die 68 %
hinter sich wichtige geführt mit ihrer
mit ihren Argumenten für eine Änderung
des Bürgergeldes glaube ich nicht aber
ich glaube dass viele Leute haben auch
viele Gespräche zu dem Thema geführt
auch im Wahlkreis und so ich glaube dass
viele gar nicht so weit vorgedrungen
sind was der bürgergeldreform alles drin
ist sondern da kommt ja in so einer
Umfrage auch so ein allgemeines Gefühl
so ein unterm Strich Gefühl raus von all
dem das ist Sachen die ich genau jetzt
gewesen naja aber ich
ärgert einfach in dieser Diskussion dass
wir über die praktischen Erfahrungen
auch aus den Jobcentern hinweggehen wenn
da seit über 15 Jahren Leuten im
Jobcentern arbeiten und zwar ja auch mit
hunderttausenden Langzeiterwerbslosen
die zum Teil von Anbeginn an in dem
System drin sind und wenn dann
politische Kräfte kommen und so tun als
hätten alle Praktiker es nicht
verstanden und jetzt bräuchte es nur ein
mutigen der die Wahrheit ausspricht dass
da endlich mal ordentlich gegängelt
werden muss bei den Sanktionen und dann
würden die Leute verstehen dass in ihrer
örtlichen Fußgängerzone überall Zettel
hängen wo drauf steht hier ist Arbeit
frei kommen doch dahin dann wäre das ein
ziemliches arbeiten
die Öffentlichkeit statt wegen der SPD
geschlafen denn interessant war ja in
der Diskussion in den letzten Wochen das
eigentlich fast nur noch über eine hohe
mutmaßlich zu hohe Leistungen in dieser
Bürgergeld in diesem Bürgergeld Entwurf
diskutiert wurde aber nicht zum Beispiel
über zu niedrige Löhne das ist ja auch
ein großes Problem das ist ja ein
spd-thema aber man hat eigentlich nur
über die Union und besser gesagt deren
Strategie viel mehr verfangen hat das
jetzt bei Bürgergeld etwas getan werden
muss um Missbrauch zu vermeiden naja
weil natürlich es leichter ist eine
öffentliche Diskussion die Millionen
Menschen am Rande zumindest mitbekommen
zu führen über die Frage der Höhe von
Regelsätzen oder über Sanktionen hat
jeder eine Vorstellung von was das ist
was es bedeutet den
vermittlungsvorrang abzuschaffen oder zu
überwinden na da brauchen sie aber ein
paar Minuten bisschen mal erklärt haben
was das eigentlich ist wie die Kultur im
Jobcentern war und wohin das jetzt
geändert wird ich bin aber nicht bereit
weil uns diese sozialstaatsreform zu
wichtig ist da jetzt in den Populismus
zu verfallen und selber nur mit ein paar
einfachen Eurozahlen zu operieren
sondern wir wollten diesen Kern des
Bürgergeldes durchkriegen und das hat am
Ende auch geklappt und ja der Preis
dafür ist dass einige Leute im moment
jetzt erstmal eine falsche Vorstellung
davon abbekommen haben was eigentlich
hinter den Türen von Jobcentern in
Deutschland tatsächlich so passiert und
das schmerzt mich einfach als Bürger
muss ich sagen für die Union ist war ja
auch immer wichtig das lohnt
Abstandsgebot zwischen Sozialleistungen
und den niedrigsten Löhnen damit sich
Arbeit wieder lohnt wäre es dann nicht
wirklich besser gewesen von ihrer Seite
sich um eine höheren Mindestlohn zu
bemühen denn das hätte ja diesen
Lohnabstand noch erhöht und 12 €
Mindestlohn das ist ähm selbst obwohl
erhöht worden ist nicht sehr viel wäre
es dann nicht besser gewesen sich dieses
Thema ist mehr anzunehmen auch aus
sozialer Verantwortung natürlich müssen
die Tarifpartner sehen dass die Löhne
steigen müssen ist doch ganz klar aber
hier gibt's auch falsche Informationen
eine Familie mit zwei Kindern die jetzt
bürgergeldbezug hat oder in Zukunft
bekommt oder jetzt hat vier die braucht
einen Mindestlohn in einer arbeitet
Geringverdiener von 18 19 Euro bei einer
Familien mit drei Kinder sind sogar 24
Euro
und deswegen haben wir ein Problem ja
wir können das jetzt nicht über
mindestlohne Löhne lösen weil sie nicht
24 Euro jetzt ist fordert niemand ich
kenne niemand in Deutschland vor allen
Dingen in manchen Bereichen nicht das
ist jetzt alles ohne Kindergeld
Kinderzuschlag Wohngeld was sie rechnen
obwohl er kühner das ist auch so ein
Problem ich kriege natürlich also einmal
kriege ich vielleicht andere Mails aber
mir schreiben Vermittler aus dem jobcen
dann ist es richtig dass wir weiter das
Instrument von Sanktionen haben auch
wenn es nur drei Prozent nutzen allein
das ist so ein Instrument gibt ist es
wichtig weil jeder Mensch ist
unterschiedlich so dass der erste Punkt
der zweite Punkt man muss natürlich auch
wissen dass diejenigen die arbeiten
gehen
noch Spritkosten haben die GEZ Gebühren
zahlen müssen und vieles mehr und
diejenigen die das Bürgergeld bekommen
die müssen GEZ Gebühren nicht bezahlen
dort wird die Klassenfahrt übernommen
ich will das jetzt gar nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen und über
Spritpreisen und sowas reden nur diese
diese Debatte dürfen wir in Deutschland
nicht unterschätzen und deswegen habe
ich persönlich meine ich jetzt
vorsichtig den Vorschlag gemacht gesagt
wir sollten den Weg von Israel oder von
UK England gehen dass wir sagen dass
derjenige der Vollzeit arbeitet nicht
mehr als Bittsteller zum Sozialstaat
gehen muss sondern er muss automatisch
über das Finanzamt Steuergutschriften
gutgeschrieben bekommen damit er auch
das Gefühl hat dass sich das lohnt
morgens aufzustehen und arbeiten zu
gehen die solidargemeinde nicht bezahlt
das ist ihre Vorstellung es bleibt dann
bei niedrigen Löhnen 10,45 € das hätten
wir ja noch wenn sich alle so wie sie
enthalten hätten und der Staat gleich
das dann über eine negativ
Mindestlohn von 18 19 Euro um von dem
Lohn leben zu können er kühn hat ich
weiß nicht was sie im Moment fordern als
SPD 13,14 € oder fordern Sie 18 und 19
€. ja aber wir kommen da nicht weiter
10,45 € und da wollten sie jetzt auch
stehen bleiben sie haben beim Bürgergeld
die Geschichte erzählt es ist der
Kassiererin ich Charaktere das jetzt
auch mal an der Stelle so nicht zu
erklären warum sie für Leute die sich
nicht vermitteln lassen wollen in Arbeit
warum sie dafür ihr sauer verdientes
Geld über Beiträge abdrücken muss aber
was sie jetzt fordern ist dass die
Kassiererin nicht nur für Leute im
Leistungsbezug was abdrückt sondern
sogar noch für ihre Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die sich über eine negative
Einkommenssteuer vom Staat die niedrigen
Löhne ausgleichen lassen was ist denn
das für eine Arbeitsgesellschaft was sie
dagegen haben diese Kassiererin muss
heute zum Start und aufstocken
Kinderzuschlag Wohngeld und da sage ich
das finde ich falsch weil übrigens bis
zu 50% des sagen Studien gar nicht zum
Start gehen aus Scham Gründen oder weil
sie es nicht wissen das kann ich doch
nicht als Politiker in dieser
Legislative hier gelten lassen und
deswegen ist mein Vorschlag also da
ausgestreckt haben warum reden wir da
nicht drüber was spricht dagegen zu
sagen dass diese Verkäuferin automatisch
das Geld bekommt was ihr zusteht als
dass sie noch zum Sozialstaat gehen muss
ich ich weiß nicht was daran so schwer
ist das zu verstehen weil es Supermärkte
in Deutschland beispielsweise gibt wenn
wir bei der Verkäuferin bleiben die ja
mehr als den Mindestlohn und zwar auch
den aktuellen Zahlen Lidl Zeit mehr als
12 Euro also warum machen Sie sich jetzt
zum Anwalt von Arbeitgebern die
behaupten man könne zu solchen Löhnen 14
15 Euro niemanden anstellen wenn doch
aber andere in der Praxis zeigen dass es
funktioniert sie erledigen hier das
Geschäft von Leuten die auf Kosten von
schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen in
ziemlich großen Reibach machen und das
halte ich für problematisch weil das
nicht die Aufgabe von diesen Verkäuferin
zwei Kinder hat und arbeitet zu
Niedriglohn gerne auch 13 14 Euro bei
Rewe oder bei Lidl was sie gerade gesagt
haben reicht es trotzdem nicht sie muss
trotzdem zum Sozialamt und da sollten
wir doch als Politik miteinander
arbeiten dass das in Zukunft nicht mehr
der Fall ist das geht ja fast in
Richtung bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
der kriegt man auch eine
Steuergutschrift und zwar ohne dass man
Anträge stellen muss wenn man wenn man
damit man offen
menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum kommt
was soziale Teilhabe garantiert was
neben würde garantiert das wundert mich
jetzt ein bisschen ich finde ihr Modell
übrigens super kommt drauf an wer die
Steuern dann bezahlt muss ja nicht die
Verkäufer sein kann ja auch der sein dem
Lidl gehört aber gut da sind wir bei
einer anderen Diskussion aber was nicht
was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe Herr
Linnemann die Frage stelle ich mir die
ganze Zeit ich finde ja die Union wenig
konsistent in ihrer Argumentation zum
Beispiel dieses Jahr im Wahlprogramm
ich habe es mir noch mal durchgelesen
man es sei Menschen die lange gearbeitet
haben nicht zuzumuten ihre
Wohnsituationen zu verändern das sei
wichtig wieso haben sie dann eigentlich
jetzt beim Bürgergeld so wie im Moment
darauf behaart dass die Karenzzeit die
unter anderem auch für die Wohnsituation
galt dass die halbiert wird weil ich
finde dass ein Jahr eine gute Zeit ist
um sich eine neue Wohnung zu suchen weil
es zahlen ja andere die
supermarktverkäuferin hat vielleicht gar
nicht so eine große Wohnung wie
derjenige der Bürgergeld bezieht dann
muss sie doch gesagt dass er nicht
zumutbar oder das das wollen sie
schützen ja aber nicht mehr als ein Jahr
das stand da nicht drin
vor zwei Jahren beschlossen dass es zwei
Jahre sein sollten das ist ja die
bislang geltende
in der Regel Herr kühner das wissen sie
beim Virus findet man schwieriger eine
Wohnung als nach dem Virus nein beim
Virus waren die die Stellen es gab ein
Lockdown es konnten die Gastronomie die
man bekam gar keine Jobs weil es quasi
eine Geschäftsgrundlage gar nicht mehr
gab weil die Läden zu waren also wir
lernen jetzt das ist neben der Einigkeit
beim Bürgergeld die ja schon etwas
beeindruckend und fast irritierend war
jetzt auch doch noch unterschiedliche
Auffassungen zwischen Regierung
Oppositionen in vielen Fragen gibt
werden wir auf die nächste auf die
nächsten Monate gespannt sein
Frau Lehmann ähm
das was sie jetzt erlebt haben dass der
Union ist gelungen ist da den Fuß in die
Tür zu kriegen das liegt natürlich auch
am Bundesrat und an den mitregierenden
unionsländern im Bundesrat das kann sich
möglicherweise durch die Landtagswahlen
im nächsten Jahr auch ändern aber war
das eine Blaupause wie in Zukunft
Regierung Opposition miteinander umgehen
dass die Ampel nicht so durchregieren
kann dass die Union sich auch nach
dieser doch schlimmen Wahlniederlage
wieder etwas gefangen hat
das war jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal ein
Ausweis für die Geschlossenheit der
Union also man hätte auch es hätte ja
nur ein Land mit fünf oder sechs Stimmen
im Bundesrat ausscheren müssen und dann
hätte man allerdings dann wäre die Verdi
Einheit gebeutelt und man hätte im
Prinzip Friedrich Merz demontiert als
CDU-Vorsitzenden die Union war da
geschlossen und sie hat es durchgezogen
und ja sie hat es geschafft das Ganze zu
blockieren erstmal und dann ist es in
Vermittlungsausschuss gegangen ich bin
mir sicher am Freitag wird der Bundesrat
ist dann auch durch wegen das liegt
natürlich auch daran dass es in den
Ländern jetzt so vielfältige
Konstellationen gibt in jedem
Koalitionsvertrag Länder
Koalitionsvertrag ist festgehalten dass
wenn ein Partner
nicht zustimmen kann dass ich dann das
gesamte Bundesland enthält und die
Situation hatten wir jetzt das gab ja im
Bundesrat ähm
als das erste als das Gesetz das erste
Mal dem Bundesrat passiert hat gab es
eigentlich bis auf Bayern
von unionsseite nur Enthaltungen und
haben sich auch SPD geführte Länder
enthalten müssen weil eben die Union mit
in der Regierung war und weil sie gesagt
hat nee das machen wir nicht mit und
zwar aus parteitaktischen Gründen
insofern ja da ist so quasi so ein
bisschen so eine zweite Kammer
entstanden die ein größeres Gewicht hat
als vorher eine Gottheit leben dass die
Politik das gerade im Bundesrat dann man
sich gegenseitig da neutralisiert und
das man einerseits auch im Bundestag
sind mehr Zeit diese klarer man muss oft
auf dem Bundesrat Rücksicht nehmen dass
da das ist so eine etwas
unübersichtliche Gemengelage in
Krisenzeiten auch ist ja aber auf der
anderen Seite ich mag diese Worte nicht
so Blähungen oder blockieren ich meine
wir haben nur einen föderales System wir
haben 16 Bundesländer übrigens 365 Bund
länderkommission so viel wie das Jahr
Tage hat und erstaunlicherweise
funktioniert das doch immer alles
relativ gut und im Endeffekt wir dürfen
ja nicht vergessen diese Wahl ist auch
relativ knapp entschieden worden ist ja
nicht so dass die Ampel ist über eine
riesige Mehrheit verfügt also man muss
immer sehen wie die politischen
Mehrheiten sind im Bund aber eben auch
in den Ländern und die Kollegen hat es
eben auch so ausführlich erklärt und von
daher gesehen wir haben dieses checken
Balance System das ist umständlicher als
meint wegen zentral regierten Staaten wo
top down entschieden wird und dann ist
es so es ist manche Leute vielleicht
auch so kompliziert aber ich glaube wir
sollten vorsichtig sein aus diesem
komplexen System was aber insgesamt
meiner Wahrnehmung nach ganz gut
funktioniert
so eine Art lernen Demokratie zu
konstruieren also und deshalb bin ich
auch immer sehr vorsichtig mit Worten
wie blockieren es ist das rechte
Opposition
Gesetze der Regierung abzulehnen es ist
das Recht der Länderkammer Gesetze des
Bundestages abzulehnen und aus diesen
aus diesem Mechanismus ergibt sich dann
etwas dafür haben wir regeln die sind
wie gesagt etwas komplex etwas
kompliziertes dauert manchmal länger
aber im Endeffekt funktioniert doch dann
alles relativ gut und wir haben auch
jetzt wieder gesehen nach dem ganzen
Kanonen donnerden und vorher angestimmt
worden ist gab es die relativ schnell
und reibungslos insofern weil sich auch
keine Seite hätte leisten können dass
das Projekt scheitert das ist richtig
schön
kannst du Dendemann ihr
Parteivorsitzender hat im Februar als
die Ukraine angegriffen wurde von einer
konstruktiven Opposition gesprochen die
die Union sein will das hat er definiert
Regierung kritisieren wo es nötig ist
Alternativen gegenüberstellen aber auch
in schwierigen Lagen helfen das Land zu
regieren also die
Opposition hilft der Regierung beim
Regieren in schwierigen Situationen
gelassen das noch ja klar wir haben den
zentralen Fragen bei der Bundeswehr mit
den 100 Milliarden zugestimmt etc aber
ich halte es generale etwas anders
geklungen ja weil daraus nichts kommt wo
sind die Bestellung wie geht's weiter
wir müssen ja mal ein bisschen schneller
werden in Deutschland das dauert ja
alles immer sehr langsam
aber das dass man am Rande es ist total
wichtig deswegen finde ich Demokratie
politisch diese Debatte mit dem
Bürgergeld eigentlich richtig gut weil
wenn die SPD und die CDU sich in der
Mitte des Parlamentes treffen und
unterschiedliche Positionen haben und
auch in der Bevölkerung ist deutlich
Wert ich gehöre zu dem oder zu dem oder
ich teile die Meinung und die dann
entsteht Demokratie wenn sie das nicht
mehr haben und das hatten wir lange Zeit
in den großen Koalition es waren zu
viele große Kohle Koalition der wussten
die Menschen nicht mehr wofür steht denn
jetzt die CDU wofür steht denn jetzt die
SPD und dann entsteht Protest und das
stärkt die Ränder deswegen finde ich das
Demokratie politisch eigentlich richtig
klasse dass wir jetzt diese
Auseinandersetzung hatten am Ende
Kompromiss steht am Freitag geht das
durch und dann gehen wir in die nächsten
Debatten rein also deswegen finde ich
das gar nicht gar nicht so schlecht ist
das für die SPD einen äh vergiftetes
Angebot diese konstruktive
Oppositionen so ein bisschen weil sie
ist auch angesprochen Prüfung haben
groko ich höre dir trapsen ist das
sozusagen durch die Hintertür wieder so
einen ein zusammenführen was die SPD
gerade auch eben dass ihr froh sind da
raus zu sein wie gehen Sie mit diesem
Angebot um das das
in der groko musste man ja alles
zusammen machen jetzt haben wir aktuell
gelegentlich eine Situation wo man bei
Sachen die auch in den Bundesrat müssen
vertieft miteinander reden muss und
darüber hinaus gibt es Themen die
einfach von nationaler Tragweite und
Bedeutung sind wo es im Interesse der
Sache ist dass man mit mehr Stimmen als
nur denen der Koalition vorgeht so wie
das beim Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr gewesen ist ich will ein
bisschen Wasser in den Wein rein kippen
also ich sehe es wäre Koffer die wir
halten uns eine Länderkammer in
Deutschland nicht als abnick Verein
sondern natürlich
funktioniert das nur wenn dort auch dann
eine selbstbewusste Position geäußert
wird wenn die der Mehrheit im Bundestag
widerspricht aber und da muss man
sprachlich sehr sensibel sein dort jetzt
nicht uns die Opposition gegenüber
deswegen ist das ja auch ein bisschen
komisch die letzten Wochen gewesen dass
Herr März so getan hat als würde die
Ampel quasi mit ihm jetzt den Kompromiss
zum Bürgergeld verhandeln
dieses Mal auch funktioniert haben aber
der Vermittlungsausschuss als
verfassungsinstrument ist eines zwischen
Bundestag repräsentiert vor allem durch
die Mehrheit die Regierung tragenden
Mehrheit der ampelfraktion und auf der
anderen Seite durch die Länderkammer und
dort sitzt nicht die Opposition sondern
in der Länderkammer sitzen
ausschließlich regierende die sitzen
nämlich in den Regierungen der 16 Länder
und ich glaube auch deshalb ist es hier
zu einem Kompromiss gekommen entgegen
dem was manche in der Union
zwischenzeitlich auch sehr lautstark von
sich gegeben haben denn in den
Landesregierung sitzen Praktikerin und
Praktiker die müssen ihren Leuten vor
Ort auch erklären warum sie etwas
blockiert haben auf Dauer was viele z.B
in den Jobcentern wollen und insofern
ist die Interessenlage einer parte
freizentrale manchmal schon eine andere
als die in einer Staatskanzlei Frau
Lehmann wie lässt sich denn jetzt dieses
Thema
Opposition Verhältnis Opposition
Regierung Angebote der Opposition auch
Angebote der Regierung in bestimmten
wichtigen Bereichen Krisensituationen
zusammenzuarbeiten auf die das
Verhältnis von Bundeskanzler und
Oppositionsführer
unterbrechen wie verstehen sich die
eigentlich das wäre die Voraussetzung
dafür dass ein solches vorübergehendes
zusammen gehen in wichtigen Fragen von
großer nationaler Bedeutung und von
großen nationalen Interesse funktioniert
wie ist es denn darum bestellt das
müssen sie eigentlich Kevin Kühnert
Fragen
aber vielleicht von außen besser von
außen ist es so dass ich glaube die
beiden haben nicht wirklich ein
Tradition sondern das mag damit
zusammenhängen dass ich glaube Olaf
scheut sich der sehr stark darauf
verlassen hat dass
Friedrich Merz wird zumindest
kolportiert sein Versprechen bei der
Impfpflicht konstruktiv mitzuarbeiten
gebrochen hat und da kann er glaube ich
nachtragend sein also dieses Angebot
konstruktive
Opposition das ist habe ich so von außen
noch nicht wahrgenommen an sich finde
ich es aber gut wer nennt man sagt dass
jetzt auch mal die Unterschiede deutlich
werden also dieses Bürgergeld das war ja
dann schon eine fast anthroposophische
Debatte um da ging es dann auch um
Menschenbilder und das ist gut dass die
Leute wissen also dieses Lager steht
dafür und dieses Lager steht dafür und
ich habe eine wirkliche Wahl
und ich muss aber auch ihnen recht geben
Herr Kühnert wenn sie sagen
in die Länderkammer sollte nicht allein
den Willen der Opposition verkörpern
also das ist nicht die Opposition denn
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass
Ministerpräsidenten wie reiner Haseloff
oder Michael Kretschmer in in
Sachsen-Anhalt dass sie wirklich beef
bekommen haben von ihren Leuten dort
weil es natürlich nicht im Interesse der
Länder gewesen wäre wenn das Bürgergeld
gefiltert wäre und insofern muss man
aufpassen dass man den Bundesrat dann
nicht zum parteitaktischen
Instrument macht also dass man nicht
überzieht
was das Verhältnis von Kanzler und
Oppositionsführer angeht
hilft das im Moment bei der Bewältigung
großer Krisen oder krisenhafter
Situation oder ist da tatsächlich
sind in einem Verhältnis sich zu
belauern eigentlich wie jetzt auch anal
Lehmann gesagt hat dass da eigentlich
wenig Draht da ist also mehr Draht da
sein müsste zwischen den beiden ich Teil
den Eindruck der Kollegen das ist
Verhältnis zwischen Herrn märz und Herrn
Schulz nicht das allerbeste ist
er wirft ihm vor dass eben auch
Gesprächsangebote die er gemacht hat
nicht wahrgenommen wurden also werfen
sich wechselt seid ihr Arroganz vor ich
glaube dass kann man auch so sehen also
der auch der Wille bei beiden vernünftig
miteinander umzugehen ist zumindest
nicht extrem ausgeprägt das gilt für
beide Seiten meiner Meinung nach und
Herr märz ist nun auch angetreten die
die Union nach dieser Ferien in
Niederlage neu aufzustellen und dafür
bedarf natürlich auch einer einfach mal
auch konturierten Oppositionsarbeit nur
durch Zustimmung gewinnt man weder
Profil und noch ist Zustimmung die
Aufgabe der Opposition das ist ihm
natürlich erschwert worden durch die
Situation die wir haben seit dem 24
februar und all den Dingen die danach in
Folge der Invasion gekommen sind
Energiepreise Inflation alles andere
aber ich glaube der Blick oder die
Hoffnung darauf dass sich denn doch der
Kanzler und Oppositionsführer ein
bisschen mehr entgegenkommen und dieses
dann hinterher auch liegende so ein
bisschen Harmoniebedürfnis ich finde das
ein bisschen merkwürdig auch heute bei
der Generaldebatte man wenn am Ende der
Regierungschef damit beginnt die
Opposition zu beschimpfen dann also
finde ich geht schon ein bisschen in die
falsche Richtung ne also insofern muss
man schon mal also die Empfindlichkeit
bei Ihnen Herr kühner ist extrem hoch
also da muss man schon mal sagen wenn
sie mal Gegenwind bekommen in unserer
gerade in Rheinland SPD hintergrünen da
gibt's schon Empfindlichkeit Gegenteil
ich mache den Job jetzt 30 Jahre als
parlamentskosten ich muss sagen also da
könnten sie ein bisschen dickfälliger
werden bei manchen Debatten und da gibt
es schon große
nicht gesagt aber
ja womit hat der Bundeskanzler seine
Erwiderung auf den Oppositionsführer
vorhin begonnen
Wunderland ich meine das ist schon so
ein bisschen immer
vorgeworfen es ist zu dröge wir redet
und jetzt bedient er sich mal eines
böses auch er hat das auch schon wieder
abgelesen das war sozusagen entgegen und
die ablassung Manuskript und es bezog
sich sofort in dieser Märchen
Formulierung ich fand es ein bisschen
merkwürdig und ehrlich zu sein in so
einer Generaldebatte also der Regierung
sollte erstmal seine Position erklären
und dafür werben und dann kann er
natürlich die anderen Kritik
zurückweisen aber er hat sich nun doch
sehr stark auf die Kritik fokussiert und
nicht auf das war sehr der Meinung ist
was wichtig ist an seiner
Regierungsarbeit und insofern finde ich
merkt man auch daran dass das Verhältnis
doch ein bisschen schwieriger ist glaube
ich weder mit den Parteien zu tun in
Fraktionen meiner Einschätzung hast
sondern eher mit den beiden
Persönlichkeiten gut es gibt Regierung
Opposition das Verhältnis ist klar jetzt
ist Kevin Kühnert in der SPD-Fraktion
ist helle Freude über die Ampel über
ihren derzeitigen Zustand wie sie agiert
oder gibt es da inzwischen auch schon
Ernüchterung man wollte ja wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere vor einem Jahr als sie
Ampel gebildet worden ist mehr als vier
Jahre zusammen bleiben das kann glaube
ich schon vorher gewissingen diese
dieser Wunsch sind sie da noch auf
diesem Weg das hat Olaf Scholz schon
auch selber gesagt und ich teile auch
wie es ausgedrückt hat er hat nämlich
gesagt der Anspruch dieser Koalition
muss sein dass alle drei Parteien als
Gewinner gestärkt aus ihr hervorgehen
was wäre auch sonst das Bild dieser
Koalition wenn man zusammenarbeiten will
mit der Ansage wir wollen dafür sorgen
dass ihr und ihr am Ende unter die Räder
gekommen seid das was man gelegentlich
Angela Merkel ein bisschen nachgesagt
hat bei ihren Koalition das ist ja nicht
die Grundlage für eine gedächtliche
Zusammenarbeit also wir wollen dass alle
drei Parteien am Ende der vier Jahre mit
Recht vor Ihre Wählerinnen und Wähler
treten und sagen können wir haben einen
Unterschied gemacht und es ist gut dass
wir daran beteiligt gewesen sind und ich
erlebe weiterhin eine Zufriedenheit
nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger
friendly fire in der also dass man sich
untereinander da das Leben auch schwer
macht diese Woche ja auch der Hinweis
aus der FDP gibt doch nach bei der
vertrauenszeit das war ja eine
Steilvorlage für den Kompromissen mit
der Union ja meine Güte also es ist es
gibt eine Grauzone und die ist ziemlich
groß zwischen Himmel hoch jauchzen und
zu Tode betrübt in Koalition aber wissen
Sie wie mir uns stecken acht Jahre groko
am Stück noch in den Knochen und das
sorgt bei mir einfach dafür dass ich
weit davon entfernt bin ein paar
knirsche rein und
Meinungsverschiedenheiten die es
natürlich in der Ampel gibt sofort für
den Untergang des Koalitionären
Abendlandes zu halten da haben wir echt
ganz anderes erlebt in den letzten
Jahren und insofern auch die Ampel ist
für die SPD und ich glaube das gilt für
die anderen auch unter den gegebenen
Mehrheitsverhältnissen in diesem
Deutschen Bundestag die beste Koalition
die wir bilden konnten und daher sind
wir zufrieden mit die groker auch gesagt
immer so oft erwähnen wie schlimm diese
Jahre waren auch eine Art Trauma
Bewältigung wie Hartz IV für die SPD man
hat mir das Gefühl also sie die Weg sie
müssen mit der Uni und nicht mehr
koalieren sie regieren ohne die nicht
sehr geliebte Union und es war ja
übrigens auch eine bewusste Entscheidung
also ich bin kein Anhänger des Begriffs
der Alternativlosigkeit und deswegen ist
auch die Ampel ja nicht alternativlos
gewesen die alternativen hätten
Jamaika-Koalition oder groko
Unterführung der SPD heißen und
eingedenkt der Tatsache dass diese drei
Option auf dem Tisch schlagen ist die
Ampel für uns also sozialdemokratischen
Perspektive mit Abstand die beste Option
weil die Schnittmengen größer sind und
weil er mit der Union die wir natürlich
die hat als eine demokratische große
Partei vom Grundsatz her auch einzelne
Überschneidungen mit uns aber die sind
nach acht Jahren natürlich dann auch mal
aufgebraucht und dann ist am Ende nur
noch Reiberei und quietschen sozusagen
und das hat glaube ich allen Beteiligten
nicht mehr so viel Spaß geschaltet der
Ampel kann sich keiner leisten das wäre
ein politischer Suizidversuch rechnen
Sie mit dem Scheitern der Ampel in
dieser Legislaturperiode sind Sie darauf
vorbereitet
glaube ich nicht dass das passiert sage
ich ganz ehrlich
das Grundgesetz ist so austariert dass
es sehr schwierig ist etwas scheitern zu
lassen
das glaube ich nicht aber ich mache mir
halt
schon als Bürger auch sorgen dass es
auch jetzt funktioniert weil wir kommen
jetzt in eine schwierige Phase und wir
brauchen in Deutschland wieder
Aufbruchstimmung und so wie die Ampel
gestartet ist mit den tollen Bildern und
davon ist man jetzt halt weit weg und
letzten sagten Journalisten ja die Union
kommen wenig vor weil die Journalisten
damit beschäftigt sind erstmal
abzutasten was wollen die die Grünen die
FDP und die SPD weil die immer oft
unterschiedlicher Meinung sind kommen
wir gar nicht mehr drin vor und dann die
Journalisten sagen bei euch jetzt noch
mit reinnehmen dann verliert der der
Lesern kompletten Überblick deswegen das
ist die Möglichkeit gehabt in dieser
Woche sich wieder richtigen Spiel zu
bringen inwiefern mit dem Bürger Geld
weil sie sagen wenig beachtet genau
übrigens auch zwei andere
Oppositionsparteien die spielen jetzt
eine Sonderrolle die kann man jetzt
nicht mit der Union sozusagen zu einem
Opposition
eine ganz wichtige Funktion jetzt hat
wir sind die größte Oppositionspartei
und deswegen teile ich das Wasser sagt
das ist verdammt noch mal die Aufgabe
des Oppositionschef hat ins Gericht zu
gehen mit der Regierung natürlich gibt
es Fragen gerade jetzt im Hinblick auf
den auf den Krieg wo wir
zusammenarbeiten müssen ist doch klar
aber wenn wir dieser Rolle nicht gerecht
werden geht Deutschland den Weg
Italiens anderer Länder es ist doch
immer der gleiche weg dass das die
Ränder gestärkt werden das Volksparteien
zu Splitterparteien werden und die
Demokratie gerät unter Druck das heißt
Demokratie politisch hat die Union jetzt
eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe hier wirklich
den Finger auch in die Wunde zu legen
ich meine wir reden muss man muss man
mal sagen wir gehen jetzt in eine ganz
schwierige Phase wo es um die Frage geht
wie geht es weiter mit den
Energiepreisen mit unserem
Geschäftsmodell mit den Arbeitsplätzen
und da ist es verdammt noch mal unsere
Aufgabe da auch richtig richtig
reinzugehen für das zukünftige Programm
der CDU zuständig wird das schon nicht
mehr zu repräsentiert wird er
Kanzlerkandidaten 2025
Fraktionsvorsitzender und Parteichef hat
nicht nur den Anspruch sondern natürlich
kann der Kanzlerkandidat werden ich
persönlich finde das gut Zugriff auch
wenn sie mich persönlich fragen als
Carsten Linnemann fände ich gut wenn
Friedrich Merz bundeskanzlerkandidaten
CD auf die Pille rückt das auch super
eine Debatte ich finde Friedrich Merz
hat das heute im Bundestag herausragend
gemacht wir seiner Oppositionsrolle
wirklich gerecht geworden ist und ich
habe da als Bundestagsabgeordneter
gesessen habe geklatscht und habe gesagt
ja genau so stelle ich mir das vor
Friedrich Merz die sagen es ist der
unbeugsame was ist an ihm eigentlich
unbeugsam dass der Titel dieses Buchs
und wir haben natürlich lange überlegt
wie wird das Buchen und was uns schon
imponiert hat Jutta Falke ichinger meine
mit Autoren und mich war die Tatsache
dass er sich auch von den doch
schmerzlichen Niederlagen nicht hat
entmutigen lassen also er war hat
ungefähr zehn Jahre draußen kommt zurück
in die Politik in einer schwierigen Lage
Frau Merkel nach 16 Jahren tritt ab
hinterlässt natürlich ein führungswache
um es gibt Kämpfe um die Spitze und in
dieser Lage tritt er eine verliert es
erstmal in Hamburg er lässt sich eine
Mutti wieder an er verliert dann
weiteres Mal ähm dann kommt eben die
ganze Wahl und die ganzen Diskussion
erinnerte Union cducc so das war alles
nicht wiederholen und in so einer
Situation aber jetzt eben auch mal nicht
auf das ist nämlich sondern auf die
Mitglieder und das auch noch mal
durchzusetzen und sich auf diesem Risiko
auszusetzen ein drittes Mal zu scheitern
um dann am Ende fast in der zwei Drittel
mehr gemessen war dann zu siegen also
das ist schon so Art von ich sag mal
auch Härte und Kampfbereitschaft und
auch sich nicht unterkriegen lassen die
zu diesem Titel
Lehmann ist er der Richtige für dich
mehr als in der jetzigen Situation für
seine Partei seine Fraktion
ja aber es wäre es rhetorisch sehr gut
aber ich finde ich widersprechen er
macht das nicht sehr gut es fehlt
einfach der inhaltliche Unterbau und
deshalb konnte auch die Ampel nicht
kommen noch mal auf das Bürgergeld beim
Bürgergeld nur gewinnen weil im
Unterschied zur Union hatte sie nämlich
einen sozialstaatskonzept und die Union
hatte nichts ich glaube die Union wenn
sie konstruktive Opposition sein will
muss mehr machen als nur zu sagen ist
doof gut ähm wir machen diese Stelle ein
vorläufigen Punkt ich bedanke mich bei
einer Lehmann bei Kevin Kühnert bei
Katzen Dendemann und bei Daniel koffert
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
morgen in der Phönix Runde im Abseits
die Fußball-WM in Katar
jetzt folgt Phoenix der Tag mit Maja
Weber darin unter anderem noch einmal
die Generaldebatte im Bundestag heute
Vormittag bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
Phoenix der Tag
willkommen liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer bei Phoenix der Tag und das
sind drei unserer Themen heute
Kinderbücher im Bundestag die
Generaldebatte gibt sich heute mal
literarisch
Konsens im Vermittlungs